now this is just spectacular uh
spectacularly horrible actually uh so
Disney has you know and you know Disney
they used to do uh you know Mickey Mouse
and Donald Duck whatever happened to
Donald Duck bring that guy back that
would be good but no they can't do that
what do they have to do they have to
turn children into little racist
ahistorical Maniacs so one of the women
you remember from a few months ago when
we showed you that leaked Zoom call
where the former CEO of Disney he has
since been fired Bob chapek was on with
the diversity Equity inclusion group and
they were all talking about their trans
kids and how they secretly put gay
messaging into people into their movies
and all of this stuff anyway that guy
got fired one of the women who was on
that panel she has a new show she's an
executive producer she's got a new show
out on Disney kids and tell me if this
is just good old-fashioned child
programming or perhaps something a
little more nefarious designed to break
your children's brains enjoy
oh
this country was built on slavery which
means slaves built this country till
this land from sea to Sea to Sea first
there was rice tobacco sugarcane Whitney
did his thing and Captain became and we
weren't soldiers four million strong
fighting for America's freedoms even
though we remained America slave built
this country this
place
and we the descendants of slaves in
America have earned reparations for
their suffering and continue to earn
reparations every moment we spend
submerged in the systemic Prejudice
racism and white supremacy that America
was founded with and still has not
atoned for slaves built this country not
only filled hands but Carpenters Masons
blacksmiths musicians
to the Northern Bank ERS to the New
England ship owner the founding fathers
former president current Senator the
Illuminati the New World Order of slaves
built this country we had Tubman Turner
Frederick D then they say Lincoln free
the slave but slaves were men and women
we can free ourselves emancipation is
not freedom
did you catch that at the end why are
they sticking it to Abraham Lincoln
Abraham Lincoln freed the slaves Abraham
Lincoln basically started a political
party because he was not happy with what
was going on with slavery uh he saved
the freaking Union maybe that wasn't the
best idea in retrospect but why why at
the end like this and Abraham Lincoln
there's such nonsense in there but
putting aside all of the nonsense and
how they're actually making a political
agenda you might look you can talk in a
cartoon you could actually teach kids a
lot of things almost everything I
learned I learned from Bugs Bunny and
Looney Tunes right but but to to push
such a specific policy agenda too that
what we have to do really kids kids I
mean who's watching this so imagine a
five-year-old watching that you're gonna
get this very distorted view of what
history was and then Mommy I want
reparations like what
foreign
[Music]